ils étaient cinq le 27 décembre 2020 à
recevoir leur première dose de vaccin
anti qu'ovide 19 parmi eux maurice est
78 officiellement première vacciner
française c'est avec ces cinq injections
qui a débuté dans le pays la campagne de
vaccination contre le colis de 19,1 coup
d'envoi aussi donné sur twitter par le
chef de l'état nous avons une nouvelle
arme contre le virus le vaccin tenir
ensemble encore mais la campagne
vaccinale en france n'a pas été un long
fleuve tranquille entre retards de
livraison début difficile et ce coup
d'arrêt en mars 2021 avec la suspension
dans plusieurs pays d'europe du sérum
d'astrazeneca motifs des suspicions de
cas de thrombose s'il a été depuis
réhabilités
il reste boudé dans de nombreux centres
de vaccination aujourd'hui en france
plus de 51 5 millions de personnes ont
reçu au moins deux injections de sérum
anti copie de 19 et l'exécutif continue
de miser sur une vaccination massive
avec notamment la dose de rappel nous
allons atteindre aujourd'hui les 20
millions de rappels merci à tous ceux
qui mobilisait comme jamais nous
permettent de nous protéger face aux
variants delta et omicron on continue on
amplifie on y arrivera ensemble
place aussi à la vaccination des 5 11
ans les plus fragiles peuvent désormais
être vaccinées depuis le 15 décembre
dernier une vaccination élargie à tous
les enfants depuis le 22 décembre mais
sur la base du volontariat
350 centres de vaccination en france ont
été préparés pour recevoir ce type de
public